DISTINCTION.
>> Tucker: IT CERTAINLY IS
AND THANKS FOR POINTING THAT
OUT.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE,
APPRECIATE IT.
>> YEP, SEE YOU LATER.
THANKS.
>> Tucker: TODAY'S REPORT
REVEALS AS WE JUST SAID THAT
IF JAMES COMEY, NO MATTER
WHAT YOU THINK OF HIS
POLITICS REPEATEDLY AND
DEMONSTRABLY BROKE PROTOCOL
AND ENGAGED IN INSUBORDINATE
BEHAVIOR.
TOM FITTON IS THE PRESIDENT
OF JUDICIAL WATCH AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
TOM, YOU ARE MAKE A LIVING
FILING REQUESTS, FOIA
REQUESTS FOR GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS.
YOU HAVE A SHARP EYE FOR
WHAT'S BEEN DELETED FROM
DOCUMENTS.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THESE
500-ODD PAGES ARE THE WHOLE
STORY OF THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE CLINTON EMAIL
SCANDAL?
>> WELL, IT'S THE BEGINNING
OF THE STORY IN THE LEAST
BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS
THIS CONNECTION BETWEEN
PETER STRZOK, CLINTON EMAILS
AND THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS YET
TO BE ANALYZED BY THE IG.
JUDICIAL WATCH UNCOVERED THE
CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL.
IT'S UPSETTING TO SEE
DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE OF THE
FBI AND DOJ BENDING
OVERBACKWARDS TO PROTECT
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND DEFERRING TO HER ON
VIRTUALLY EVERY ISSUE AND
DECIDING EARLY ON NOT TO
PROSECUTE HER AND JUST GO
THROUGH THE MOTIONS OF AN
INVESTIGATION DESPITE ALL
THE EVIDENCE THAT WE HAD
UNCOVERED THAT SHE KNEW WHAT
SHE WAS DOING WAS
INAPPROPRIATE, SHE WAS
WARNED BY HER NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM AND SECURITY
TEAM NOT TO DO IT.
AND THAT SHE DID IT TO AVOID
DISCLOSURE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
ALL OF WHICH GOES TO THE
HEART OF GUILT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HER INTENT WAS FOR
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
I THINK -- YOUR VIEWERS NEED
TO LOOK AT THE REPORT
THEMSELVES.
DON'T TRUST THE MEDIA
ANALYSIS OF IT BECAUSE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> THE DOCUMENTS SHOWS THAT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT WAS
DESPERATE TO PROTECT HILLARY
CLINTON WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME AS THESE TEXTS INDICATE
WAS GEARING UP TO GO AFTER
DONALD TRUMP AT THE VERY
SAME TIME.
SO, WHEN YOU COMPARE AND
CONTRAST WHAT HAPPENED WITH
MRS. CLINTON, WITH WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH HILLARY-BOY
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP, THESE SAME
PEOPLE WERE WORKING WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, FUSION GPS
TO TARGET AND SPY ON THE
MAN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT.